هنا بالقرب من المنزل التي قام الذي قامت
قوه الاحتلال فجر هذا اليوم بتفجيره تعمل
حاليا اطقم تابعه لبلديه مدينه الخليل
لازاله الركام الذي تناثر في كل الانحاء
في هذه المنطقه في منطقه قيزون في مدينه
الخليل هذا هو المنزل الذي تم تفجيره وهو
منزل الشهيد محمد الجعبري حاليا تعمل
البلديه على ازاله الركام في المنطقه
المنزل الذي تم تفجيره هو في الطابق
العلوي من عماره او بنايه سكنيه تتالف من
خمسه طوابق يسكنها سبعه عائلاتهم اشقاء
الشهيد محمد الجعبري تم اخلاء الشقق
السكنيه بالكامل مساء يوم امس مع وصول
قوات الاحتلال التي حاصرت المنطقه ومنعت
الوصول اليها وبدات باخلاء السكان من
البنايه السكنيه ولكن ايضا تم اخلاء ما لا
يقل عن 50 عائله
تسكن في محيط هذه العماره السكنيه لتامين
عمليه تفجير المنزل هذه العائلات قضت
الليله الماضيه في العراق بالاضافه الى
عائله الشهيد وعائلات اشقائه الشهيد محمد
الجعبري المتهم بتنفيذ عمليه اطلاق نار في
منطقه الخليل اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطن واصابه
اخرين